dass sie wirklich einfach mal einen
daumen hoch gibt wenn ihr sagt jan luca
bleibt weiter megaprojekte macht nur
videos wenn du bock hast aber dann halt
weniger aber mache auf jeden fall immer
so ein bisschen megaprojekt und gibt
einen daumen runter wenn ihr sagt lueg
ag bitte raus aus dem megaprojekt macht
auch keinen sinn wenn du so notgedrungen
videos machst
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge vom mega projekt und
soll diesmal eine sehr kurze folge die
ich sogar gerade um 17 13 aufnehmen also
kurz bevor die folge wahrscheinlich
heute noch online kommen wird und zwar
ich geh mal ganz kurz auf den server
seiner drauf und sogar jemand drauf ich
möchte allerdings jetzt gerade nicht mit
dem anders aufnehmen weil ich mit mit
was euch mit euch was bequatschen möchte
und zwar fängt ja bald das projekt von
simon anhui das fängt ja aber das
projekt von simon an und dann neigt sich
ja das mega portier so ein bisschen
alter ach ja das war als wir das gemacht
haben hat ich weiß nicht wer es war den
war es glaube ich hat man mit einem
feuerzeug gesehen aber ich bin mir nicht
sicher ich möchte jetzt auch kein was
unterstellen
wer halt auch bei rot pilzen in den
links angezündet hatten
pilz
wieder habe ich dann so wenig leben ich
hab gar nicht zufrieden mit
jedenfalls ist halt die hälfte von
meinem dach mehr oder weniger weg und ja
also mega projekt ist mittlerweile fast
nur noch chaos und ich habe da jetzt
auch nicht mehr so lust drauf also
deshalb den letzten folgen
wahrscheinlich einige mich da schon
angesprochen ob irgend wie lust bei mir
weg ist weil ich auch zum beispiel den
letzten folgen nur sachen gemacht habe
wie zum beispiel mit revidieren
diese ganzen blumentöpfe die jetzt
irgendwie auch bei mir hier überall sind
dann halt bei allen anderen halt diese
bluttat vorgesetzter anhalt bei jedem
song kuchen gesetzt so von dehner und
mir war dass er so eine aktion dann was
habe ich noch gemacht ich hab mit komme
diesem weg da hinten weiter gebaut und
was alles immer so sachen so weil sie
nicht die man halt immer so
zwischendurch machen konnte so ein paar
witzige sachen und so was alles weil ich
halt nie so richtig wusste was ich hier
noch so machen soll jetzt kommt
natürlich wieder so leute an meinen ja
bla bla bla bla bla hier
es gibt so viele sachen in twist und
hier wenn man hier so rein guckt moment
es gibt hier so viele seiten was so
alles noch erforschen kannst und das ist
so unglaublich viel luca ja das mag ja
sein allerdings jetzt ich mir also den
wert so ein projekt das mache ich so
lange es mir spaß macht und es in dieser
unterhaltungsfaktor steht bei mir vorne
letztes in der konfi hat kräftig zum
beispiel gefragt ob ich aufnehmen möchte
ich dann einfach gesagt so an du nie die
motivation ist bei mir zurzeit ein
bisschen weg fürs mega projekten arbeite
google sich rein und da meinte er halt
ich bin der beste rap in der hütte also
hat er nicht gesagt aber wenn ich
natürlich
jedenfalls hat dann selbst gesagt ja was
hat eigentlich alle mit motivation hier
es gibt so viele sachen machen kann
ja aber das ist für mich nicht so
motivation also ich finde es toll wenn
leute so übels viel kraft
selbst oder park oder letzten jahr
player auch das ist auf jeden fall mega
cool wenn die da auch so spaß dran haben
nur ich finde es halt nicht so toll
irgendwas explodiert da die ganze nacht
das bei simon dieses dings man wenn man
aber gleich dass ein bisschen und hier
liegt was denn hier los
hier liegt es nicht da liegt ja bla bla
bla bla also ich lege mir da die ziel
ist ein bisschen anders bei mir muss
immer so ein bisschen
ich weiß nicht ich machen projekt so
lange es mir so richtig spaß natürlich
so sagst du scheiße ich hab's noch
folgen aber ich möchte noch aufnehmen
mittlerweile mega trucks ist immer so
dass man grund sucht warum man aufnimmt
das ist auch der grund warum zum
beispiel den rausgegangen ist oder
zornig oder sub prime dass die einfach
so nicht so bock auf dieses projekt mehr
hatten und ich habe zwar noch lust so
aber ich möchte ja ich weiß nicht ich
das so sagen soll also wisst ihr ich
denke immer so aber die leute wollen
megaprojekt aber zurzeit habe ich nicht
so bock auf aufnehmen ich würde es halt
am liebsten gerne so aufnehmen dass ich
das halt nur aufnehmen wenn ich auch
erhalt auch so bock drauf habe
das neue projekt was jemand plant wird
der hexe sein das hat er schon geplant
beziehungsweise schon gesagt und text
ist natürlich noch mal was ganz anders
als wie du bist
deswegen würde ich euch quasi frei
stellen weil ich halt auf dieses projekt
nicht mehr so lust habe mich halt schon
mega auf das projekt von simon freue
würde ich euch jetzt halt so fragen bzw
unterscheiden lassen dass sie wirklich
einfach mal einen daumen hoch gibt wenn
ihr sagt jan luca bleibt weiter
megaprojekte macht nur videos ende bock
hast aber dann halt weniger aber mache
auf jeden fall immer so ein bisschen
megaprojekt und gebt den daumen runter
wenn ihr sagt lueg ag bitte raus aus dem
mega projekts macht auch keinen sinn
wenn du so notgedrungen videos machst
also da gibt einfach mal eure meinung
aber nicht in den kommentaren in den
kommentaren könnt ihr von mir aus gründe
schreiben warum mir das so und so
bewertet habe dann aber jetzt mal
wirklich so daumen hoch geben und zwar
scheißegal also gebt den daumen hoch
also es ist nicht egal aber jetzt ist
scheißegal wie viel die sex oder so das
video bekommt deswegen daumen hoch wenn
ihr sagt sie ja mach immer mal ein
bisschen megaprojekt zwischendurch auf
ein headset läuft und daumen runter wenn
ihr so er so weit so ja
du macht man lieber gar keine mega
projekt mehr dass es eben ein bisschen
doof und sport alles also das könnt ihr
euch jetzt selbst aussuchen und das war
es auch eigentlich schon von mir ich
möchte euch nur kurz eben diese
botschaft rüberbringen und ja weil ihr
habt den letzten folgen bemerkt wo ich
dann einfach mal in folge gemacht habe
ich einfach nur um gelaufen bin habe ich
in folge gemacht durch den weg ein
bisschen mitkomme gemacht habe und dann
habe ich eine folge mit riesigem 858
holz gemacht haben und dann mit denen wo
wir diese ganzen kuchen gesetzt haben
dann wird jetzt hier zum beispiel diese
ender drachen aktion wo mein haus bleibt
drauf gegangen ist also ihr habt schon
so gemerkt das war mehr so richtig ich
habe versucht so nochmal motivation zu
finden allerdings ist es zurzeit echt
einfach nur wieder mega projekt
aufnehmen so ist es bei mir zurzeit
gerade kann auch sein dass sich das
widerlegt und wenn mehr mag ich da sind
als nicht mag ich also mag ich nicht
dann heißt es ja dass er auf jeden fall
manchmal megaprojekt wollt dann geht die
motivation vielleicht kommt ja dann bald
auch wieder muss ich schauen einfach auf
dauer und sonst werde ich mich jetzt
erst mal wieder anderen projekten widmen
eventuell auch mal gta wenn ihr das
wollt also einfach nur so fanden luca
oder hin zum scheiße und dann würde ich
sagen leute gibt eine bewertung ab wie
ihr euch entscheidet und dann sehen wir
uns beim nächsten mal wieder ciao